foreign
make your partners look awesome one of
my favorite strategies to grow business
is to partner up with somebody who
already has your target market and find
a way to work together where they can
help promote you to Their audience right
it's it's such a great way to grow your
business because for you to go one by
one by one by one by one the customers
takes a lot of time takes a lot of
energy you might get fried out before
that happens or if you could connect
with influencers other businesses other
experts other media personalities
whatever it is who already have an
audience then by connecting to that one
person they help spread your message
it's an awesome way to grow business and
I've done a lot of videos on it but I
want to share a specific strategy about
making your partners look awesome and
explain a personal story so right now
just before just before filming this I
created a video for a new partner for me
his name is Tim schmoyer he runs a
YouTube channel called video creators
and it helps YouTubers who are trying to
get started and grow their Channel and
I've gotten some great from Tim and I'm
a subscriber and I've commented on his
channel and we said hey we should work
together and this is great for me
because he has a large audience of
entrepreneurs you know YouTube
entrepreneurs and I have a message that
can help them and by me making a video
on his channel
and him promoting it I'm reaching a
whole new audience who will come to my
channel learn about me want to subscribe
and hopefully become engaged but I want
to make Tim look awesome right this is
what a lot of people are missing in the
partnership strategy you don't go into
that with the mindset of you know what
can you do for me I want my partners to
look awesome I want this video that I
make on Tim's channel to be the best
video that has ever come out on Tim's
channel so I put a lot of effort into it
I put more effort into making teams
video than I do for my own videos I
created a list and said here's what I'm
going to talk about and that took a lot
of time and thinking and writing to send
to him and then making a video I've got
16 17 18 different clips something like
that tons of takes tons of mistakes
that'll make for good bloopers start
that over ah
stressful all because I want to make
Tim's video awesome I want my partner to
look awesome now when the video comes
out I'm not just going to leave it to
Tim to promote it I'm going to promote
it too I'm going to share it on my
channel I'm going to share it to my
audience I'm going to let my people know
that I made this video because again I
want him to look awesome I want him to
think wow Evan was such a great person
to work with because maybe we can work
together again or maybe I can refer Evan
to somebody else right so you need to
put in the effort to make your partners
look awesome you don't go in with a
mindset of what can you do for me but
how can we do this together and what can
I do for you because I want to help
whatever I make for you become the best
thing that you've ever released that
needs to be your mindset and when you
have that mindset and you put in the
effort and you make amazing stuff
your partner's win and you win
so partner up but make them look awesome
and believe for those of you watching
like the video subscribe to the channel
to see more just like this thank you so
much I'll see you soon
and don't forget for my best information
join my newsletter and get on the
believe team today
hi I'm Jason J Ross Fonseca
rizonline.com and I want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's the only
newsletter I prioritize and look forward
to period